[Musica]
mi sono tormentato ma il lupo ma quella
è unita come va al succo e il giardino è
una storia un po lunga ma ti ricordi
niente di che cosa di quello che è
successo ieri sera
no che cosa è successo mi fanno un po
male le braccia e la schiena ma come non
si ricordi niente per un lupo mannaro
volevi mangiarmi mangiarti non credo
proprio
non vorrei mai mangiarti lei o caldo
torno dentro spetta ti devo spiegare che
cosa è successo perché non mi credi che
sono mi sembra di non aver dormito per
tutta la notte
e infatti è così non hai dormito tutta
la notte ti sei trasformata in lupo mi
ha rincorso volevi sbranarmi è quindi
direi che è problema che sia un po
stanco ma che dici se mi fossi
trasformate in lupo sarei ancora lupo
nomi dormire non loro no aspetta meglio
se non ti addormenti che strumenti
ritrasformi di nuovo il lupo si sa mai
guarda che insomma che ti risvegli di
nuovo lungo un sogno troppo stanca
lasciami in pace si sta addormentando
devo trovare un modo per tenerla sveglia
svegliati lasciami
[Musica]
tutte le volte che proverei ad
addormentarti tirano rom pupazzo ma ho
bisogno di dormire regia ei metti la
moto non smetterò sveglia mettine a che
cosa stai facendo
sono stata io a ringhiare avete visto
anche voi e marino sei stato tu a
ringhiare no non è stato berlino berlino
vuole mangiare tutti i pupazzi bel senti
io sono troppo stanca torno a dormire
senza spetta aspettava una cosa per te è
una lettera da parte del lupo te lo
ricordi il lupo al lupo
sì mi ricordo di lui e come lasciato
questa lettera per te c'è un sigillo con
un lupo vediamo cosa si è scritto
una lettera scritta male c'è scritto
ciao anita per fortuna la tua prima
notte da completo lupo mannaro è andata
bene non hai fatto nessuna vittima
il capo è molto arrabbiato per questo e
anche perché vi aiutati ti contatterà
molto presto fai tutto quello che ti
dice almeno fino a quando non avrai
rotto la maledizione si forte come un
lupo firmato l che cosa dovremmo fare
adesso che il capo di cui parla non lo
so non te ne ha parlato no mi ha
salutato la lettera mi ha solo detto che
quando ti ha morso stava solo eseguendo
gli ordini del suo capo non ne ho idea
di chi sia quindi lui in realtà non è
cattivo non mi ha morso per trasformarmi
il lupo mannaro
no non credo forse come dice lui stava
solo seguendo gli ordini non lo so come
ho fatto chiudersi la porta
sta arrivando qualcuno o no
chi è
chi sei
e berlino dimmi tu che è meglio della
robur taciuta qualsiasi cosa sia non
voglio che entri qua
[Musica]
una lettera un'altra lettera il sigillo
diverso come il sigillo diverso che
cos'è un lupo un ufo sono lasciato
questa lettera aprile secondo voi
lasciate un mi piace qui sotto se volete
che offriremo leggiamo questa lettera il
simbolo e della falsa di un lupo e c'è
anche una chiave qua spero che non sia
una trappola
un'idea facciamola annusare a berlino è
lui con il suo intuito rifiuto
riuscirà a capire se una trappola o se
possiamo aprirla ottima idea per lui non
ci ha sempre aiutato in queste
situazioni vorremmo chiedere te lo sei
merlino guarda dimmi se pericoloso se
posso aprirlo che è senza mangiarla però
è sempre di sì e berlino sembra completa
e meta provando a potenze fare le cose
non possono che sta provando ad aprirla
quindi vuol dire che dobbiamo
decisamente aprirla sì come me non si
sbaglia mai
grazie per il tuo aiuto berlino grazie a
berlino sta ancora provando a mangiarla
ma io la pro adesso no berlino non si
mangia
[Musica]
ok vediamo che cosa c'è dentro una
lettera ciao anita però tu ti sia
divertite a scoprire la forza e i poteri
no berlino non vuoi te lo leggo marino
non vuole che lega la lettera perché che
c'è berlino potrebbe farmi male cercando
di fermarmi per ridurre poi per forza
leggerla potrebbe esserci qualche
indizio qua non capisco cosa vuole dirmi
merlino si legge lo dai
vediamo che cosa dice svanita spero tu
ti si è divertita a scoprire la forza e
i poteri del lupo mannaro ma non pensare
che sia finita qui infatti ad ogni luna
piena tornerà il lupo mannaro cosa avevi
ragione non è fantastico ah ah ah se
vuoi rompere la maledizione
dovrai superare tutte le prove a e poi
ovviamente ci sarà la prova finale a
casa ma ora è meglio che inizi il
viaggio perché il tempo sta passando e
la prossima luna piena si avvicina seguì
la mappa e ricorda se non verrai lupo
mannaro per sempre rimarrà e firmato il
re il re il re di col bayern
ma c'è qualcosa qui
sembra non appaiono sembra la mappa del
tesoro ma non penso che sia la mappa del
tesoro ma gli diceva dovrà iniziare il
viaggio ho capito dobbiamo metterci in
viaggio
dobbiamo fare queste varietà che guarda
c'è un castello dei lupi questo non so
cosa sia un portale che cosa è questa
chiave invece ma che cosa servirà meglio
portarla con noi
quante saranno le tappe soprattutto dove
dobbiamo andare prima al castello forse
penso che il primo percorso sia il
castello come ha detto nella lettera
più tempo passa più la luna piena si
avvicina io potrei tornare lupo mannaro
e potrei realmente sbranarti quindi
dobbiamo sbrigarci dobbiamo fare tutte
queste tappe
secondo voi sarà pericoloso che cosa
succederà una volta che arriviamo al
castello presto dobbiamo metterci in
viaggio subito dobbiamo partire subito
perso questi punti prima che torni laura
piena e anche il percorso da seguire
e voi verrete con noi ci porterete
fortuna che cosa succederà secondo voi
lasciate un mi piace per portarci
fortuna qua sotto
iniziamo subito il viaggio si andiamo
[Musica]